そうだよ
また帰る?
今もずっと一人じゃない?
日本のおじいちゃんと一緒に歩くなんてことはあんまりないからね
うんうん
でも別にトシコさんと転化したり
そういうのは全然ないよね
トシコさんとも話をする
もう一回行けばいいのに
行ってみたら
今朝も何か行ってたよ
うん
それでなんかあの
しばらくずっと
前一番最初にもあったの
その時もなんかとても親切だったんだけど
普通にね
普通に荷物持ってくれたり
ちょっとスロックスイングが知られて
それであの
ずっと会わないで
そしたらなんか
お気に入りのことにしてもね
ずっと焦りてたんだけどね
おとととに急に思い出したんですよって言ったのね
それで
おととに思い出してくれたみたいなんだけど
そうは言わないから
うんうん
だから
おととぐらいもたほうがちょっと思い出したんだって言ったから
そう?あの
不思議ねって言っちゃったの
それでね
その時はそんなこと考えてもなくて
なんか、それは大失敗だと思う。 車みたいだと思われてると、みんなに思う恥ずかしい。
いやいや、おかしいだけだって。
別にね、そんなすごくね、 すごいやー、会いたいなとか、そんなこと書いてないんだけどね。
いつ作るから、どこかって言いますかとかね。 そういうようなことを書いてあげたけど。
あと、電話で見るとさ、一人ずつのさ、 書くのとさ、いろいろいっぱい入ってる人の文、 同じように見えるじゃん。
ああ、そうね。
いや、何回もやったことあるよ、それ。
うん。
でも、インターネットっていうか、あの、 パソコンとか、文字ってないのかもしれない、こんな感じなの。
電話でね、電話でね、そうやって、 書くと書いて。
うん。
そうだよね。
ああ、おいしぱ。
ああ。
でも、リキュリキさんなんて、とっても、あの、 何だろう、国物だから、いろんな面で、だから、あの、 女の子にもってるんです。
そうが、こうです。
いや。